everybody was up lay here I'm here with
Todd lemon Todd lemon writer top 11 and
today we're in Chicago Illinois and we
are doing remote the time keep up with
explain to everybody where we're going
to be doing today okay well since
Chicago is be blues town I thought it
would be fun to have Conan to go meet
some real people in Chicago to find out
what's getting them down what got them
depressed right some flu songs based on
that threat some hard-hitting flus and
who are these people who are going to
hear about their problems they are six
and seven year old Elementary
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ooh today's remote in this awesome
library up here I was looking around and
they've got a couple books that I found
pretty interesting Aaron Loup hey listen
they got one over there about storms I
was looking at it's pretty dope there's
nothing wrong with being a late bloomer
was one laughing there's nothing wrong
to Layton one two three yeah exactly
yeah I was just saying this is like all
unusable so good going to make me stop
doing behind the scenes just playing
Clair blush
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
children are animals child and in handle
I think yeah kids today the great
nice job kids huh Francis Xavier Ward
school and we hope you enjoyed this
little peek behind the scenes of the
coded plays the blues with the kids
remote see you guys next time
[Music]